we got Michael B Jordan the director and
the star of Creed Three and you know we
know each other we go way back all the
way to Chad science in Newark okay right
I did not say that misquoted for sure
[Laughter]
he said hey when I was the corny kid
right you aren't aware basically these
two went to high school together some of
the resorts and bikes will be like yeah
I remember you the one who used to call
me corny if you don't know who Michael B
Jordan is you guys remember him from
Black Panther or Creed or a little other
movie went from The Young and upcoming
actor on The Wire who played some lanky
looking weird kid to now being one of
the world's most famous actors and and
the thing is she didn't say that in high
school also she has a podcast where she
said that Michael B Jordan is just like
a nice corny guy and I don't mean that
as a slight right I mean we all know
that the nice corny guys treat you the
best you know it's so crazy I went to
school with Michael B Jordan out of and
to be honest with you we tease them all
the damn time because his name was
Michael Jordan like like let's start
there and he was no Michael Jordan and
then he also would come to school with
headshot and back then that was like in
in the we lived in Newark yeah like that
that's the hood you know what I mean so
it we would make fun of him like what
you gotta do with your little stupid
headshot so a lot of people think Mikey
B Jordan's a bit corny okay
what does corny mean think of nerdy not
cool
lame that's pretty much synonymous with
being corn so the most hyper successful
actor currently out there at the moment
behind maybe just the Rock and one other
person is being called corny by these
women so let's keep listening no you did
not hear anything I said we used to make
fun of the name
yeah
looking like a Cheeto with that orange
hair yeah what's up Oompa Loompa yeah
okay I love
pettiness everything about the energy
I'm a fan of keeping the same energy
and when you said something and then
you're gonna go back and
back in the knob
you said that [__] on it you said that
[__] on it corny's generally reserved
especially for black men who aren't The
Stereotype of what is cool what it means
to be almost hood or thuggish you get me
you get called corny for having good
grades you ain't called corny for not
using certain vernacular you get called
corny for like an anime you get like
corny for not being into athletic stuff
or basketball whatever you get got corny
just because you dress preppy or
whatever it might be I remember the word
lame corny two white being thrown around
liberally
for anything and whether you like it or
not when people say stuff like that to
you it sticks with you it does even for
this guy the most hyper successful dude
possible right now he remembers that
stuff internally that guy who got got
Courtney still lives inside of there and
it probably propelled them to want to
work extra hard to make it it's also
probably why he can't stop around
because he used to get no play a high
school game called corny all the time
now that he's Top Dog you like I ain't
just gonna settle down right away
right now this is me taking a liberal
leap but I'm just saying
that kind of [__] sits in your psyche so
it's just interesting the way the word
is important it's just crazy to me how
doing things that are the markers of
success in life is corny doing it
legally to some people is corny
and that's something that's a bit sick
in the psyche of people because you
don't act like a [__] boy or do all that
extra stuff oh you just a nice guy
that's kind of corny you know what you
show up to a girl you said I actually
like you and I like to go out to dinner
uh you bring flowers or whatever corny
but if you've been playing all kinds of
games all of a sudden Hey listen I bet
you these same women who said that [__]
back then today wish they had themselves
a corny [__] they wish they had
themselves a corny [__] because them
dudes who is running game getting them
pregnant or doing this all this [__]
they didn't stick around
they was busy running game on a bunch of
other women because that's not corny nah
that's player yo
last time I took a plane this is what
they gave me yeah this wonderful little
bundle of joy the problem with those is
that you can't hear nothing uh it always
it's just in my ear so you know what I
mean
bash them away what I use now when I
travel is the raycon earbuds it comes
with five different types of gel uh
there's an awareness mode there's a
noise isolating mode as well so you can
perfectly ear the sound that comes out
of those earbuds and the other
competitors far too expensive we offer
the premium sound at half the price and
not only that but they're also water
resistant yeah
when I travel it's trained too water
resistance because I'm sweating and
everything and stuff and they don't fall
off
look let me show you
see
where you at go to the link in the
description below or go to buy recon.com
to get 15 off on us he is obviously
killing things out here favorite
restaurant here oh man uh whatever Hotel
I'm in that restaurant
well you're not corny anymore
eat it you gotta eat that my girl that's
a good ass L that you have to eat
yeah
I feel like you're living vicariously
through him what's up what's up I am
because he was probably corny in high
school oh [__] yeah bro oh [__] yeah bro
they call me all sorts of [__]
all sorts of names all sorts of [__] go
ahead yeah
go ahead oh
I'm scared they're corny revenge of the
corny yeah let's go go ahead let's go I
love I love what yeah
it does feel kind of good because yeah
back in my school it was okay with some
of the ladies it was it was all right
but yo some of the guys are ruthless
maybe it's because of some of the ladies
were okay with me but I was called phony
by a lot of [__] and then
you're gonna slide to my DM talking
about ah
I really like what you do now nah B I
remember what the [__] you said back
then what's up with that
and now the fact that she is
interviewing I love the fact that she's
the one interviewing m
um and he's not letting that [__] slide
yeah I heard you
I heard you when you said I heard you
yeah just want to put you on notice I
know who you are I remember you I mean
we didn't talk about yeah we go way back
like we was homies and [__] we was not
homies
we go way back but we was not homies
okay we go way back but I know what the
[__] you used to say yeah talk about my
drip talk about my name talk about our
corn hour
yeah going way back doesn't always mean
that she was friends
[Laughter]
[Music]
one of the reasons I got called corny
well one of the reasons I got corny I
got called corny or gay was because when
I was alone with a girl I was not trying
nothing
that's kind of good
no you had to it was for the comedic
relief
he was alone with a girl you didn't even
try to no I was trying to do nothing no
no no no no no no no no no I didn't have
that confidence or whatever what not and
I was trying to I was trying to I was
trying to respect a [__] you
know I mean if you want something you
should say something that's how I was
raised respecting women I know Corey gay
bruh Broly gay dudes respect me no so
the thing that's gonna be their friends
what you gonna do [__] hold her purse
yeah okay go ahead sorry no no but that
that that's what it was that's what it
was and yes I'm like okay so I'm not one
of these guys like that in that case it
was sometimes a girl's calling me that
Ray won't try nothing true okay I'm like
what what are you talking about come on
cause my mama raised no food you gonna
tell me what yup
that was me that was my high school
right there that was my high school my
elementary school I wasn't trying
nothing I was gay or corny Hey listen I
think I understand his energy and you
know like I remember watching him on the
wire he wasn't that dude but you could
tell he really worked my man put in that
effort some people did the wire and
never went out to do anything else but
whatever was fuel hidden probably a bit
of that resentment for how he was raised
and how he had to overcome stuff
probably got them to where he is today I
think um people can say whatever they
want horny or not if that's what it
means to be Corner that I guess I want
to be corny too
it is what it is that's why I stopped
being ashamed of my nerdum over a decade
ago you like Anna yeah I do you don't
like it take a hike you like yeah I do
and what you still gonna get this dick
so why the [__] you complaining
okay
I don't make fun because you like to
dress up like a clown and wear makeup
but here we are nonetheless you know the
thing is even even
I call you nerd all the time because you
are but I'll be a nerd too
no
no now that it's cool to be a nerd
everybody's a nerd I'm not cool it's not
cool to be a nerd it's still corny no no
it's cool to be a nerd now it is 100
socially cool to be a nerd but it
depends what kind of nerves and what's
that what do you what do you what are
you projecting as a nerd nerd nerding
I think tech savvy geek is okay and cool
nerd nerd like magic cars and [__]
anyways whatever you say what you say
but I didn't did it is what it is you
know the way I talk about Firearms the
way I talk about certain Sports the way
I talk about this and that whatever
still nerdish this no bigger Firearms
Enthusiast is a nerd now okay
this is what I mean this is what people
have you have people have appropriated
the term so hard it's actually crazy
have you seen the people in that in that
in that realm they're nerves bro
but but okay maybe it's not cool it's
not cool you're not a nurse it's an
Enthusiast all right cool listen you say
you like guns and you're into guns
people don't think nerd
but if that's what you want to claim go
ahead no they don't think nerd but they
look at you the same way as is you're
crazy or why would you like such a thing
and that's why people appropriate it as
yeah you're nerdish because people
actually think you're crazy and you
shouldn't be loving such a thing you
know I mean if I see a
um never mind if it's not nerdy it's not
nerdy all right I was just agree to
disagree you can make your case though
go ahead the public wants to hear what
you have to say there's no case it is
what it is I feel like that people are
looking at you the same way for the same
reason they think you're crazy for
liking something like that and knowing
so much and putting so much effort and
time into something like that that they
deem useless right so maybe to y'all
it's cool and everything firearm is cool
and everything and stuff but to the
general public it's not cool and it's
not okay and it should never be someone
that's something that someone is an
Aficionado why do you know so much about
Firearms you're not even in the Army
you're not even a policeman you're not
even they think they think that so what
do you do for a living for you to like
Firearms I'm a comedian well guns are
not funny like they don't they don't you
know they look at you like a nerd they
look at you like a uh was there a grown
ass man and you like cartoons
ugh you're not a kid no more grow up
like they look at you the same way but
it is what it is stay corny my friends
yeah let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear from
you